todos los ojos están puestos aquí sobre
el aconsejo constitucional fuertemente
custodiado desde hace varios días esta
institución entregará su decisión en la
que dictaminará si el texto de la
Reforma pensional está acorde o no con
la Constitución ya sea parcialmente o en
su totalidad o si por el contrario es
completamente inexequible lo cual
quedaría sentenciado que pues se
tumbaría la reforma pensional sin
embargo para varios expertos
constitucionalistas Esta es la opción
que menos chance tiene de ser En todo
caso los miembros de este consejo nueve
y que se les conoce como los sabios
tendrán que dejar de lado sus
consideraciones políticas teniendo en
cuenta que dos de ellos fueron primeros
ministros uno de izquierda uno derecha
incluso hay otros dos de estos miembros
que fueron ministros de la primer
gobierno de Manuel sin embargo lo que se
sabe es que también las decisiones del
Consejo constitucional tienen muy en
cuenta el clima político y de cómo sus
decisiones pueden afectarlo Así que
algunos creen que aquí podría intentar
calmar un poco los ánimos tras más de
tres meses de protestas en las calles en
contra de esta reforma otra de las
decisiones que se esperan es también si
da vía libre o no a que se realice un
referendo de iniciativa compartida r&p
por sus siglas en francés Pero para esto
se necesitarán recolectar al menos
cuatro coma ocho millones de firmas de
electores franceses Ese es el
equivalente al 10% de El electorado galo
sin embargo los sindicatos dijeron que
están dispuestos a irlas a buscar y que
están seguros Además de que van a poder
conseguirlas esto es digamos el punto
que puede dar más esperanzas sobre todo
a la movilización Y a lo que los
sindicatos van a ser en los próximos
días mientras tanto el presidente
Emmanuel dijo que una vez se conozca la
decisión de este consejo constitucional
Pues citará a una reunión a los
sindicatos del país